Pirates
gangsters villains and the worst of
humanity swallowed up by the sea but why
were they ripe for the wrath of God or
are there deadly Natural Forces at work
what if you could drain the ocean to
reveal the secrets of the sea
floor now powerful new technology can do
just that digital photos and sonar scans
give us remarkable new insights into a
world Beneath the Sea what apocalyptic
disaster wiped out the pirate city of
Port Royal it's a city that was
literally swallowed by the Sea and what
are the dangerous forces that made
Alcatraz the rock the most infamous
prison on Earth the conditions
surrounding this island is what really
made it an escape proof prison drained
dry we reveal the extreme extreme
geological forces that led to the demise
of so much
wickedness deep beneath the waves is a
reminder of the Earth's violent
beginning through the use of cuttingedge
Technology we can reveal the secrets of
the sea floor in astonishing detail and
expose the Shaky Ground on which we all
live in the 17th century Port Royal on
the south coast of Jamaica was an
English stronghold at the heart of the
Spanish Empire dominating what would
become Kingston Harbor from the end of a
long spit of land if you've seen the
Pirates of the Caribbean movie the first
town you go to where we meet Jack
Sparrow is Port Royal grown fat on the
profits of piracy and slavery Port Royal
was a city of almost 8,000 the ultimate
Boom Town of a new world
but it was also known as the wickedest
city on earth it certainly had more bars
and brothel than any other city in the
whole of the English colonies for the
port indeed is very loose in itself is
now more rude than a was Sodom filled
with all manner of
[Applause]
debauchery on June 7th
1692 disaster struck Port
Royal a massive earthquake wiped 2/3 of
the city off the map sending it to the
Bottom of the
[Music]
Sea today archaeologist John Henderson
an expert in sunken cities will use new
technology to discover C just how the
disaster
unfolded Port Royal sank so fast that it
took its secrets with
it this is a true sunken city but not
only that it's a catastrophic site it
went down so quickly that it's sealed a
moment in time it's sometimes called the
the Pompei of the new world it's now
underwater for us to discover and that's
really rare in
archaeology John's mission is to
ReDiscover the sunken city and recreate
a precise Digital model of its
ruins data that explains how the city
tore apart in 2 minutes of
[Applause]
Terror it's a huge challenge but if it
works we can virtually drain the
ocean strip away millions of gallons of
water and bring the sunken city of Port
Ro Royal back into the light of
[Applause]
day draining the sea Beyond Port Royal
may explain why it became a pirate
powerhouse it's all down to its
location right at the entrance of
Kingston
Harbor pulling the plug on these
Caribbean Waters reveals one of the
largest natural
harbors
at 10 Mi long and 2 mi wide it's large
enough to shelter hundreds of ships from
the hurricane whipped tropical Seas
better still was the long finger of land
on which Port Royal was built one of the
things we'll see is the spit coming out
into this very deep Harbor its steep
sides made it the perfect location to
dock
ships you had deep water on either side
large ships could come up and get very
close to the sure very
quickly this might seem like an ideal
spot to build a port but made of
constantly shifting sand the spit would
be Port Royal's
undoing the main problem is there is no
solid geology down there for a very long
way so in an earthquake when that starts
to shake you're in
trouble I very much doubt that anybody
in Port Roy
realized they were sitting on a Time
Bomb John Henderson is here with
photographer Simon Brown to photograph
the sunken
city with bad underwater visibility
Simon must get as close as possible to
the ruins and take thousands of
images after 3 days the many photo
photos have been compiled into a 3D
representation of what lies on the
seabed okay Simon show me what we've got
then it's not been easy but we we've
captured quite a lot of building
five building five May once have been a
grand family
home All That Remains of it now is one
room showing up in unprecedented
detail I mean this looks fantastic given
the conditions you were working in I
mean we can see they've got the wall you
can actually see the courtyard next to
it you can see the fire pit you can see
the low walls this is great we can
actually see the individual bricks
themselves for me what's exciting is you
can show that to someone and they can
instantly see what's actually down there
didn't think you would get results as
good as this John's mission is
delivering spectacular
results we're beginning to reconstruct
for the first time in 300 years really
what exactly is there
now we can examine the most famous
pirate City from every angle and shine
light on the extraordinary disaster that
sent thousands of people and hundreds of
houses to the
depths but Clues to its wickedness still
lie hidden in
darkness
since the 1950s three archaeology
Expeditions have sifted Port Royal's
underwater ruins to uncover its pirate
past and in the 1980s a team discovered
part of the fabric of the city itself
during that 10 years we excavated five
buildings pretty much completely it the
most exciting excavation I've ever
conducted today we use science to map
these discoveries right across the
sunken
city thousands of relics from a lost
world all Clues to Port Royal's
cataclysmic final
day because this is a catastrophic site
it sealed a whole range of of goods that
were being used at a particular Moment
In Time Each one is an insight into the
17th century world of Caribbean pirates
so we can get actually snapshots and
glimpses into daily life from pter table
wear to Chinese porcelain and signs of
personal
wealth the archaeological record at Port
Royal shows how quite Rich it was
because usually towns in the new world
are impoverished copies of those in
Europe whereas Port Royal actually
Stacks up against the capitals of
Europe but how did Port Royal grow so so
rich the city was built from the wealth
of stolen Spanish
treasure in the 1650s England and Spain
were at
War Jama and English territory in the
Caribbean lay surrounded on all sides by
the Spanish main from Florida through
Mexico and South
America to gain the upper hand over the
Spanish the English Enlisted the help of
pirates in 1657 the lieutenant governor
of Port Royal actually invited the
Pirates to come here and to act as a
kind of unofficial Defense
Force to the English government Pirates
Who attack Spanish goods and bring to
English ports could be an asset Pirates
were licensed to raid the Spanish at sea
or on land they became known as
Buccaneers or
privateers what happens in Port Royal
really is State sanctioned piracy and in
Port Royal at the heart of the Caribbean
the Buccaneers were perfectly placed in
Striking Distance of the main shipping
routes between the new world and Europe
if the Spanish are going to try and get
anything home they have to get it past
Port Royal so it's rather like a fox
sitting in the middle of a chicken Coupe
full of
chickens Port Royal became the
buccaneering capital of the
world by agreement the English crown
took a quarter of the
plunder the rest was shared amongst the
Pirates on one of the very first
buccaneering Expeditions
1659 the fleet brought back the modern
equivalent of $75 million
us the Spanish wealth that hits Port
Royal and periodic waves is
colossal massive injections of cash
transformed this fortified Outpost into
a Boom
Town the drained City exposes as many as
2,000 brick and Timber houses crammed
into Port Royal
streets home to a growing population of
almost
8,000 the crowded narrow streets would
become a death trap when the earthquake
struck we're on a very enclosed very
overcrowded Peninsula we've got people
living here Side by Side in two to four
story dwellings when the earthquake
struck there was nowhere to
run
from the thousands of Clues uncovered
from Port Royal seabed there is one
chilling piece of evidence of when the
earthquake
struck a 17th century pocket watch its
hands long since rusted in the
sea but closer analysis of the fine
reveals something intriguing when it was
x-rayed it was seen that the hands had
actually stopped at
11:43 now we know from hisorical records
that the earthquake apparently hit just
before noon and this has been taken by
some to say that the hands of that watch
stopped exactly when the earthquake
struck but what powerful Natural Forces
set the earthquake in
motion to find the answer we're draining
the ocean not just from Port Royal but
from the whole of Jamaica to uncover the
source of the
earthquake hidden in darkness thousands
of feet beneath the
water as you drain the ocean from around
Jamaica what you see is these giant
furrows in the in the seabed they're
fracture lights running East West and
they faults they're earthquake fault
wines The Faults form part of the
boundary between two pieces of the
Earth's crust the North American Plate
and the Caribbean plate to the
South both constantly on the
move it's a place where the the gradual
motions of the plate either side get
snagged stress builds up essentially
it's an earthquake
zone and Port Royal sits right in the
middle of it and in the case of
1692 that stress that had built up very
very gradually over time gets Unleashed
into this this huge earthquake
as the stress in the Earth's crust is
released it propels a powerful seismic
wave into the
surroundings June 7th
1692 doomsday at Port Royal begins like
any other day there are daily prayers in
the churches business begins at Sunrise
people were just going about the
business traveling up to 5 m per second
the seismic pulse was heading straight
for Port Royal those records of one guy
about to go and have sherry with the
lieutenant governor that
morning there was no indication of what
was about to
come Port Royal's Alleyways and
buildings were full of people its Wars
and docks crowded with Merchant
ships I think the first indication we
got is is a a bang of noise in the North
in the mountains and and I kind of low
rumbling well the records we have
suggest there was three Pulses from the
earthquake it was what's to come that
was the real
killer for the shake was so violent that
it threw people down on their
knees chasms opened up in the ground we
felt the house shake and saw the bricks
begin to rise in the
[Applause]
floor the ground he weaved and swelled
Like a Rolling swelling
sea people ran for their lives from the
falling
masonry but the city offered no
refuge Port Royal was almost the worst
case scenario really tall buildings made
a brick with narrow streets so if you're
in those streets it's almost impossible
your choice whether to stay in a
building and to get in the street is
it's a lot of
the earthquake was just the beginning it
alone doesn't explain how Port Royal
plunged into the sea it would sink for
an entirely different
reason scientists call it
liquefaction for the people of Port
Royal it was hell on Earth the Sandy
ground where they built their houses
turned into a deadly Quagmire so what
happens with liquefaction is you've got
sand with lots of water in it and as you
shake it it turns into a slurry it
liquefies rarely captured on camera this
footage reveals the horrors of
liquefaction at work in nigata Japan on
June 16th
1964 the energy from a massive
earthquake separated the grains of
sediment below the city allowing water
to rush to the surface Earth turned to
quicksand sucking the city
Down The Unlucky people of Port Royal
wouldn't have known how solid land can
become liquid
death minutes into the earthquake the
second catastrophe
unfolded as the ground sheared open
water and sand erupted from
it the longer the ground shook the more
liquid the sand became grand houses
churches taverns and even Port Royal's
forts sank like stones those houses
which back just now appeared the fairest
and loftiest in these parts were in a
moment sunk down into the Earth and
nothing was to be seen of them some
people were trapped half in the sand and
half out the Earth received up to their
necks and then closed upon them
squeezing them to death with their heads
above
ground many of which the dogs
eat many perished in this quicksand but
there is one incredible Story of
Survival a French Merchant Lewis gy
found himself sucked into the ground
everyone thought he was dead and then in
the succeeding shock he was spat out
into the sea and he survived by swimming
to the nearest boat after which he
became a a really religious
man in all 2/3 of Port Royal sank taking
with it 2,000 souls and hundreds of
buildings it's reported that the city
took only minutes to disappear into the
sea but the chaos that the earthquake
had Unleashed wasn't
over
on the drained lost city we can reveal
extraordinary evidence that the
earthquake delivered one last shock to
Port Royal embedded in the seafloor are
the skeletal remains of a large ship she
lies right amongst the ruins of a house
on Lim Street well the clear question is
why is there a ship sitting on the floor
of a building in Port Royal the strange
Discovery was excavated in the 1980s by
by Donnie Hamilton now John wants to
find out exactly what it tells us about
Port Royal's day of Doom what we see
here is a planned view of building five
and building four we came across a
Timber which turned out to be a kill of
a
ship but how could a ship presumably in
Harbor crash into a house in the middle
of
town would the IDE identity of the
stricken ship solved the
mystery when Donnie's team searched the
records They revealed a possible
Contender an English warship measuring
74 ft
long similar to this ship she was called
HMS
Swan we knew from the records that the
swan was in the harbor at the time of
the earthquake and it fits the basic
dimensions of the ship that we found in
building 4
it turned out that on June 7th
1692 HMS Swan was being served at Port
Royals
Wars all Clues point to one
conclusion you have a ship that would
have been sitting in the harbor good 200
ft away from this building has now been
deposited launched actually on top of
it I mean it's quite clearly evidence of
a
tsunami the tsunam tunami was the third
cataclysm to hit Port Royal one
eyewitness account tells of the sea
retreating from Kingston Harbor before
the wave
hit it was a wave similar to the
tsunamis that devastated Japan in 2011
and Thailand in
2004 the tsunami would explain what
happened to HMS
Swan empty of ballast HMS Swan was like
a cork on the mighty wave that crashed
over Port
Royal she was hurled across the drown
City washed down Queen
Street finally crashing into a house on
Lime
Street piercing its walls with
considerable Force
the archaeologists have mapped the fate
of Port
Royal Port Royal was laid to waste by an
earthquake
quicksand and tsunami
waves the disaster left the city cut off
from the
mainland all that remained was a
devastated Island and thousands of dead
bodies
a multitude of whose corpses floated a
great many days after from one side of
the harbor to the other caused such an
intolerable stench that the dead were
like to destroy the
living when news of the disaster arrived
in Europe it seemed that God had finally
delivered his judgment on the wicked
pirate City when the news reaches the
Home Country there's quite a widespread
feeling that the wicked City in the
English-speaking world has just got its
Just Desserts so it was seen as divine
retribution it was seen as just
punishment for the lud and terrible
behavior that took place in Port Royal
by this terrible judgment God will make
them reform their lives for there was
not a more ungodly people on the face of
the
Earth Port Royal never recovered its
former
glory
the trading Jewel of the Caribbean was
wiped off the face of the Earth it's
interesting to think if the earthquake
hadn't actually struck here that this
place could have developed somewhere
like Manhattan or somewhere like Hong
Kong but in the end it was Port Royal's
lethal location on an active fault Zone
and deadly quicksand that sealed its
[Music]
fate half a world away California lies
on one of the most infamous fault zones
in the world and right offshore is an
island that might just be the safest
place when the next big one
hits
Alcatraz the rock Uncle Sam's Devil's
Island America's worst Al Capone Machine
Gun Kelly and Whitey Bulger all called
The Rock home the island lies within
sight of shore but Escape is almost
impossible prisoners who tried were met
with some of the Bay's most powerful
forces the island of alcatra sits alone
in the middle of San Francisco
Bay within this dramatic landscape
Alcatraz and the remnants of the
renowned US federal prison are just over
a mile from the Heart of the City
for 29 years it held some of the most
dangerous and notorious criminals in
history officially no one successfully
escaped the run but why exactly was no
inmate able to break out of
Alcatraz today the island is a museum
run by the National Park Service over a
million people visit every year one man
has watched it rise to become one of
America's most visited
attractions Ranger John kwell he's
worked on the island for over 25
years where I'm standing is on Broadway
this is the main Corridor in the
cellhouse alcatrez being a supermax
Penitentiary meant that you had high
security one officer for every three
convicts they were constantly being
watched 12 times a day they would have
counted every convict in this
Penitentiary building
but its true strength as a prison can't
be explained just by the thickness of
its
walls or the vigilance of its
guards the waters around the rock were
also a deadly barrier to escape now
science can explain just how and why the
bay was so
dangerous draining the San Francisco Bay
reveals Alcatraz as a pinnacle of
Bedrock emerging from the sea
Flor it's surrounded by mountain peaks
all of them are ancient survivors from
an age of
earthquakes Tom Parsons is a
geophysicist with the United States
Geological Survey he studied this area
for
decades so we're standing at the Golden
Gate and we're standing on mountains
that were formed 100 million years ago
yeah we're sandwiched right between the
San Andreas and the parallel Hayward
fault both of which are helping to
accommodate plate motion here between
the Pacific and North American plates
San Francisco sits right on the edge of
the North American Plate as the Pacific
Plate grinds North past it stress builds
up along the major fault lines in the
area the Hayward fault and most notably
the San Andreas uh this region is very
volatile it it produces large
earthquakes we've seen seen them in 1906
1868 both were devastating earthquakes
in San
Francisco the nightmarish effects of the
1906 earthquake 7.9 on the rter scale
are a reminder of how the area's violent
geology threatens the existence of a
great
City over a 100 million years ago the
landscape here was entirely
different there was a third plate
between the two larger ones called the
Falon the Falon plate used to sit
between the Pacific and North American
Plate it was shoved underneath the North
American Plate over all that time the
movement of the Falon plate was the
catalist that created San Francisco Bay
and Alcatraz as it ground under the
North American Plate this process is
called
subduction as the Falon plate
disappeared fragments of the Earth's
crust were forced upwards creating a
valley and mountains the Alcatraz was
part of the Coast Range belt that was
uplifted by the subduction of the Falon
plate the Bay Area was then a Long
forested Valley with a number of Rocky
Mountains one of these mountains was
Alcatraz 10,000 years ago as the last
ice age came to an end
the area was deluged by billions of
gallons of meltwater this created what
we call San Francisco
Bay Alcatraz became an
island this 1853 photograph shows the
tip of the drowned Mountain as a
featureless rock in the middle of the
bay Alcatraz may look tranquil and
isolated but it's surrounded by powerful
Natural
Forces what earned the island its deadly
reputation and what may have happened
during attempted
escapes over three decades there were 14
daring Escape attempts from the island
the story of one of these is
legendary probably the most famous
escape attempt would be the 1962
breakout Frank Lee Morris and brothers
Charles and John angland devised an
audacious bid for Freedom the escape
attempt was incredibly ingenious it
involved stealing an immense amount of
material dozens of rubber raincoats glue
electric motors to turn into
drills the guys even made a periscope
they made a
flashlight now they had to use these
homemade tools to breach the Prison
Walls
[Music]
them we're in one of the angland
brothers cells and they were ingenious
to actually create a portal at the back
of their cell and they fashioned a drill
made out of a vacuum cleaner engine put
a diamond bit on the end of this thing
and then poked holes through the
concrete to loosen up uh the concrete
around the air
vent dummy heads were made out of
concrete material human hair glued onto
the heads and the face is painted on
these heads and at night with the lights
down it looked like they were sleeping
in their
cells so in the cell housee the lights
go out at
9:30 that's basically when they make
their break once the lights are out the
heads are in place they go up to the
roof top and they've got from 9:30 to
6:30 the next morning to make it to the
mainland with over 50 rubber raincoats
glued together alcatra escapes Frank Lee
moris and the angland brothers made a
makeshift raft and life
vests it was their Lifeline to Freedom
They carried everything to the roof and
dragged it down to the water's edge so
so this is the actual spot where they
entered the water Frank Lee Morris and
the angland brothers came down this
Hillside they dragged their raft
inflated it at the seaw wall here jumped
in and took off into the
night they searched the waters looking
for these three men and the raft or the
men were never found the official FBI
documents State the three men and their
raft were most likely swept out to
sea their bodies were never recovered
but is this what really happened were
they lost at sea or could they have made
it to the mainland to understand the
fate of the three escapes on their raft
scientists are studying the geology of
the bay itself can the seabed offer an
answer first Patrick barard from the
United States Geological Survey explores
the underwater landscape at the mouth of
San Francisco Bay Bay he's hoping
analysis of the seabed will explain the
powerful currents that surge around
Alcatraz making Escape attempts so
dangerous today we're going to be
mapping from the Golden Gate Bridge West
toward the outer
Coast the investigation begins under the
most iconic location in San Francisco
Bay draining the water from under the
Golden Gate Bridge reveals a huge Gorge
it's far deeper than the rest of the bay
large enough to hide a 30 story building
but what happens to the seabed when the
multi-beam vessel heads West to the open
ocean as the boat moves farther from the
bridge the water grows much shallower
the sonar readings suggest a dramatic
transformation in the Seascape below the
bottom is changing we're seeing a lot
more sediment on the sea floor now
draining the water reveals an incredible
sight we're starting to see some very
large sand waves here that are emerging
from the depths of the Golden Gate
straight these formations on the seabed
are
huge so the largest sand waves are about
200 M long 6 M High the biggest ones 10
m high or about three
stories and they're sitting just yards
away from from the harbor
entrance they look like probably what
the Sahara would look like if you were
walking through
it these giant sand waves are caused by
the huge tidal rush through the Golden
Gate straight the fast moving water
picks up sand and then dumps it as it
slows down you have all the sand and
gravel being carried along and forced
through this narrow opening and then as
the opening widens further and further
all this material gets deposited in
these bed forms
the drained landscape shows how the
geology of the seabed shapes the
powerful tidal currents in San Francisco
Bay first the deep gorge funnels the
water into a
jetstream moving West beyond the bridge
we follow the seabed as it rises from
over 300 ft deep to just 130
ft the drain shows how the racing
current dumps thousands of tons of sand
creating these giant sand waves up to 30
ft
high but what does this underwater
landscape have to do with escaping from
Alcatraz these racing tides are what the
inmates had to contend with when fleeing
the rock is it possible that Frank moris
and the angland brothers got caught in
these Wicked currents the records from
the 1962 FBI investigation show the tide
charts on June 11th from 9:00 p.m. to
3:00 a.m. there was a strong outgoing
tide which peaked at exactly 11:46 p.m.
so when did the three escapes hit the
water in their homemade raft from the
moment lights out happened which I think
was 9:30 as soon as they could have they
would have gotten out of their cell give
it an hour hour and a half to have
gotten everything that they needed to
through that vent on the roof cross the
cell housee down the other side hit the
water I think that they started paddling
as soon as they got to the water let's
say
11:00 the three convicts would have been
in the water at Peak tidal flow during
an ebbing outgoing
time what were their chances if their
flimsy raft made of raincoats broke up
leaving them to swim in the powerful
currents if you tried to escape off the
North End of the island especially
during ebbing tide like they did in 1962
where the currents are extremely strong
and moving straight out to sea it would
very difficult to swim out of that
current within an hour and a half you
could have been on the open Coast so
moris and the angland brothers had to
struggle with the fastest and deadliest
current flow in the bay what happened to
them is one of the great alcatra
Mysteries since the 1962 Escape from
Alcatraz there have been wildly
different rumors about the men's fate
some claim to have seen the three men on
the mainland but this conflicts with the
official FBI report into the Escape
which states that their objective was
Angel Island a 2m paddle north of
Alcatraz they did what nobody else ever
did they got off the island with a head
start and and were never seen
again the official Bureau prison report
on these three men in the raft is that
the raft took on water the men were in
the San Francisco Bay they became
hypothermic and the currents took them
out to the
Pacific but this was never proved and
when the story broke around the world
there was excitement and Intrigue you
appears to be the first successful
Escape in the history of the Maximum
Security Prison for weeks the FBI
searched the bay their goal was to find
them dead or
alive the Escape triggered the greatest
man hun in San Francisco's
history though they never discovered any
trace of the bodies the FBI did find
evidence of the Escape they recovered
two of the inflatable life vests they
recovered uh two of the plywood paddles
found floating in different places in
the bay another one of the life vests
was recovered outside the Golden Gate at
a beach north of the Golden Gate there
was no lack of evidence that they
escaped draining San Francisco Bay
reveals how powerful currents on the
surface that swept men to their deaths
are shaped by The Contours
below but for the three inmates if they
did reach the open ocean there was one
more deadly challenge because of its
high population of great white sharks
this area is known as the red triangle
in June of 62 it would have also been
during upwelling season like it is now
so you have lots of nutrients in the
water column lots of fish and lots of
bigger Predators so it's likely there
could have been more great whites in the
area than there are during the rest of
the year so if they made it this far out
Dead or Alive they may have become prey
for the great
[Music]
whites the bodies of the three inmates
were never found the infamous prison
closed its doors in
1963 with a perfect
[Music]
record officially there were no
successful escapes from Alcatraz though
many
tried
the conditions surrounding this island
is what really made it an escape proof
prison the bay was the most formidable
of the prison's walls you could say that
the Bay has really created Alcatraz
reputation the perfect prison was the
result of extraordinary
geology deep Gorges giant underwater
sandunes hard Bedrock pillars at the
Golden Gate straight powerful currents
and even great predators that roam the
waters outside the bay all natural
phenomena that made the rock
inescapable but there is another Mighty
natural force at work in San Francisco
Bay that dwarfs even the power of the
ocean currents a drained Pacific Ocean
reveals the first clue deep under the
waters off the coast of San Francisco
lies the infamous San Andreas Fault the
shifting tectonic plates have caused
major earthquakes in the past the most
deadly in 1906 over 3,000 people lost
their lives but could an even deadlier
earthquake hit the area the so-called
big one so in our forecast we actually
consider an earthquake that could start
at the southernmost part of the San
Andreas fault run all the way along
through the bay area up North involves
the entire San Andreas fault Zone that
earthquake would be on the scale of 8.2
to 8.4 in
magnitude the devastation would be far
greater than the destruction caused by
the 1989 Quake if we were to see an
earthquake of that scale in San
Francisco would cause unfortunately a
lot of casualties many buildings would
collapse freeways and infrastructure
type things would be uh in danger you
know if it did happen I think we would
see significant destruction in the city
and throughout the Bay Area throughout
California the massive earthquake could
cause parts of the city to topple into
the
sea much of the downtown core
destroyed the Golden Gate Bridge pushed
to its engineering
limits but when the fire and Smoke
Clears one place will still be
standing
during a big earthquake alz would be a
safe haven because it is built out of
very strong Rock it's not going to
collapse under strong shaking like soft
soil would it's been there for 100
million years it's hung in there and so
it's going to do well during an
earthquake if the geologists are correct
and when the San Andreas lets go
Alcatraz is the safest place to be that
is the ultimate irony the the island
that so many men wanted to get away from
is the place that's going to offer The
Refuge by draining Alcatraz and exposing
the secrets hidden on the seabed a
different picture of the island emerges
the explanations behind its most
legendary Mysteries involve more than
just the prison itself the geography of
San Francisco Bay the waters the Rocks
the wind and the farm a tightly woven
net making Alcatraz an inescapable place
unless the big one hits
draining the waters around Port Royal
and alcatra Island revealed deep
powerful geological forces at
[Music]
work